This is the poinsettia.
Also known as
la flor de nochebuena,
The Christmas star,
The lobster flower,
The flame leaf,
Euphorbia pulcherrima,
And, one of its oldest names,
cuetlaxochitl.
In the US during the holidays, this plant,
usually potted with bright red and
green leaves,
can be seen everywhere.
But the history of how itgot here
is less obvious.
And it’s all wrapped up in the controversiallegacy of this man:
Joel Poinsett.
Poinsettias are native to this region,
fromMexico down into Central and South America.
The Aztec called it cuetlaxochitl,
meaning “flower that withers.”
And unlike the potted varieties we see today,
in the wild these plants look like tall
shrubs
that flower in the winter season.
It was a prized plant.
The brilliant redcolored leaves
(which are leaves and not actually petals)
were used to dye textiles,
while the sap of the plants was used medicinally.
And by the 17th century, likely because ofthose red leaves
that bloomed in time for the holiday season,
Spanish friars used the flowersto decorate elaborate nativity displays in Mexico.
Spanish-speaking Mexicans named it la flor denochebuena,
the flower of Christmas Eve.
And for many in the country, it becameforever linked to Christmastime.
For hundreds of years, common knowledge of the
plant was largely containedto where it grew natively.
That is, until Joel Poinsett.
In 1825, Poinsett,
a diplomat, amateur botanist, and South Carolina native,
wasappointed as the first ever US minister to Mexico.
As the story goes, he cameacross cuetlaxochitl in a town called Taxco,
took some cuttings, and shipped them offto the US to distribute to his botanist peers.
Eventually they caught on in the US, too.
They were debuted at an 1829 flower show in Philadelphia.
Nurseries began to growand distribute the plants in the US.
And its popularity as the“Christmas plant” exploded.
The name “poinsettia” stuck,
asa way to celebrate Joel Poinsett's legacy.
One that would grow to include not just
minister to Mexico,
but US Secretary of War,
and founding member of the institutionthat would later become the Smithsonian.
But his legacy is a tainted one.
Take Poinsett’s time as minister to Mexico,
where he aggressively attempted toincrease American influence in the country.
One letter to Secretary of State Martin Van Buren—
focused on the potential to “enlighten minds with liberal ideas” —
revealed his thoughts onthe Mexican population,
stating the Spaniards’ “...constant intercourse with the aborigines,
whowere and still are degraded to the very lowest class of human beings…
contributed to render theMexicans a more ignorant and debauched people.”
Poinsett, a slave owner himself backin the US,
believed racial hierarchy between the indigenous and “white Creole”population
could help progress in Mexico.
Poinsett also sought to expandAmerican borders.
At the time, the US looked like this…
and he was tasked withnegotiating a deal to buy Texas from Mexico.
But, before he could negotiate that deal,
heended up meddling so much in Mexican politics,
that he was asked to leave thecountry.
It happened like this:
By helping to establish a network of freemasongroups,
known as the largest international secret society,
he helped to gather menin Mexico with pro-American politics.
Eventually, that organizing laid thegroundwork for a public, pro-America political party in Mexico to gain steam,
angering many within the Mexican government.
His interference with local politics createdso much conflict
that Mexicans even coined the term “poinsettismo”
to describe“officious and intrusive conduct”.
And in 1829, at the request of the Mexicanpresident,
Poinsett was removed from his post.
A few years later, after returning to the
US…
he was appointed US Secretary of War.
In that role, he oversaw the forcibledisplacement
of an estimated 20,000 indigenous Cherokee people from their homes,
topush them west as a part of the Indian Removal Act.
It was part of the ethnic cleansing knownas the Trail of Tears
that would go on to displace roughly 100,000 indigenous people.
That cemented Poinsett’s place in history,
a man who believed in American
expansion,
at all costs.
Back in his home state of South Carolina,
Poinsett’s name lives on in many ways:
a state park, a highway, a hotel,
even a statue.
Though, his most well known namesake
is likely, still the plant.
Poinsettia production grew even more after years of engineering,
creating fuller and more compact plants.
Today, it’s an industry wortharound $170 million in the US alone.
And importantly, it's a market the UShas cornered,
while shutting Mexico out.
Due to decades-old sanitationlaws,
there are restrictions on Mexican poinsettia growers
who wantto export potted plants to the US.
It means the vast majority of the plants we seein stores in the US,
are grown here.
Though, in recent years,
many have found a, different,
small way to honor this plant's history.
By rejecting the name poinsettia,
andusing its Aztec name,
cuetlaxochitl.
A name that, hopefully,
reminds people ofthe true origins
of the plant of the season.
Thanks for watching this Christmas edition of Missing Chapter,
our series that explores how our past connects with our present.
This year, we’ve covered everything from reparations in New Zealand
to Native American sign language.
You can find a link to all the episodes we’ve made in the description below.
For each episode, we spend weeks reporting,
speaking with experts, and poring over archival images and documents
to present fact-checked stories.
You can help support our journalism — and keep it free —
by making a gift to Vox at vox.com/support-vox-video.
With your support, we’re able to keep telling these stories about hidden histories.